hey guys it is that day of the week
where you can get all caught up on
what's been happening in gaming and
pretend you saw all my news episodes
from the rest of the week it's cool i'll
leave you here's what's been happening
good news with Star Wars fans as 3 ps2
era Star Wars games are now available to
buy on ps4 Star Wars racer Revenge of
star wars jedi starfighter and Star Wars
bounty hunter were all included with the
star wars battlefront ps4 bundle but if
you didn't pick that up you can now grab
them individually all the games feature
upscaled 1080p graphics as well as
trophies and support for playstation
services like share play remote play
with vita and activity feed belgian
hunger and racer revenge are also
available on ps3 and the games cost 10
bucks apiece
the existence of the hotly rumoured
single-player dlc for GTA 5 is in
further debate this week as one of the
primary voice actors claims to know
nothing about it Ned Luke who plays
Michael DeSanto wrote on Facebook
everybody wants single-player DLC I know
nothing about that don't know when it's
going to happen or even if it's gonna
happen he added that he is set to attend
a number of conventions alongside the
actors who embody gta5 are the two
protagonists GTA 4 had to post release
expansions so there's a very good chance
we'll get single-player dlc for GTA 5 at
some point in the future
this week we got to look at gameplay
footage which allegedly came from a
playable prototype of the cancelled star
wars battlefront 3 a Reddit user posted
up the rough footage which gives you a
look at what the game may have been it
was in development at free radical
design who was subsequently folded into
Crytek the user explained after a lot of
work I managed to get my hands on star
wars battlefront 3 and wanted to share
the infamous cancelled game that I'm
sure many of you wanted to play
reportedly a build of the game is
playable on xbox 360 dev kits and a
number of videos from the prototype have
been popping up online recently
lucasarts had never actually confirmed
that battlefront 3 was in production
despite a number of attachments to its
existence Microsoft didn't want to keep
you waiting any longer for news on the
next Xbox one system update so they
dropped some this week the social
feature focused update which is now
accessible to preview program numbers
lets you see who's in a party before you
join it and includes a gamer score
leaderboard menu in your achievement
section the patch will also enable you
to rearrange homescreen pens and
introduce a bunch of other features that
you can read about in detail in our
story on site the update is expected to
learn sometime next month finally a fire
emblem fate has altered a controversial
scene for the game to Western release
Nintendo issued a statement to Nintendo
World Report that read in the version of
the game that ships to the US and Europe
there is no expression which might be
considered as gay conversion or drugging
that occurs between characters the scene
in question concerns a gay woman named
solel who can be romanced by the male
protagonist by spiking her drink which
makes her perceive the genders of all
the characters to have switched she can
then fall in love with the male
character in the form of a woman and
when he switches back she rolls with it
and keeps her feelings as this could be
interpreted as a strong suggestion
toward drugging and conversion therapy
to alter sexual orientation Nintendo
have decided to leave
out slamming it down in that comment
section what you cared about this week
and how you feel about the altered fire
emblem seen this week on site I tell you
about a load of delayed games you can
actually get your hands on this year on
the shift things you missed digs into
the epic Suicide Squad trailer and the
lobby goes over how the division plays
that is everything I happy this week
adds always be sure to have yourselves a
great weekend and I will catch you again
on Tuesday after Australia's public
holiday